[Music]
the car cougars are going for a fifth
consecutive state championship nobody in
America has ever done but we always
believe it can be done
our aspirations was to build a best team
in America and people kept saying we
couldn't but man it's hard to think
about that when you see people getting
killed
former wide receiver to let George was
shot to death in the Algiers
neighborhood of the city the Relentless
pursuit of saving a child
easy to say that harder to do it
when we lost him it changed our message
of our program people think it's all
about football but it's really about the
lessons that you learn
Ed Champion is how you fight through a
person I don't want to release No
balloons for no funerals I won't release
the balloons when they graduate when
they go to college
if they want a whole they aspire to be
great we have to give them greatness we
have to instill that greatness in them
because that's what they aspire to be
[Music]
I love each and every one of y'all to
death
[Music]
[Applause]